foreign
hi welcome to today's episode of Cold
Fusion before I start this episode isn't
a recommendation to buy any of Apple's
products in fact I'm a Windows and
Android User myself
the following is simply my documentation
of what I perceive to be the biggest
moment in Computing history in the last
decade or so I think it's just
fascinating so make sure you're
comfortable for this one get out the
popcorn and be ready to be entertained
or learn a thing or two
Fusion TV
foreign
hates Apple these days and there's some
rationale for that
recently they've made their products
impossible to repair increased prices of
their products and accessories to a
ridiculous level and enjoy excessive
control
but what if Apple actually did something
to push the industry forward and spur
competition
well it turns out that they may just
have done that
phones and computers are never seen as
comparable when it comes to power they
both live in different worlds
though as long time subscribers would
know back in 2012 I was comparing the
two of them and seeing if a phone could
replace a PC
the rate at which phone Power was
improving year over year was absolutely
unbelievable to me at the time those
were some fun days
the main difference between phones and
desktop computers is that they use
different types of processor technology
phones use a type of processor design
called arm while desktop computers
generally use another type called x86
like Intel for example
arm is a simpler design than x86 making
it more efficient but x86 traditionally
used to be able to do more but this is
changing
the interesting thing to note is that in
recent years our phones have been
getting faster at a much more rapid rate
than computers have been improving
so here's a question
what happens when the chips in our
phones come close to the power of laptop
and desktop computers what if you took
this amazing performance and efficiency
of a mobile chip and put it in the body
of a laptop that is access to a larger
battery and more space to breathe
well things that many thought were
impossible begin to happen
and then I didn't plug it in for four
days totaling a little over 10 hours of
mixed use and still had 17 percent less
animations are buttery smooth as you'd
expect and even opening and closing some
of those bigger apps like Chrome and
Lightroom are just as fast if not faster
than on my desktop which is sick it's
just an overall really responsive feel
okay look at this guy
okay Angelica when you're editing this
show the footage from the Surface Pro X
uh
how that was the windows version of this
there was extreme lag moving and doing
anything and here it is extremely smooth
and this is the base model MacBook Air
without a fan these M1 Macs are setting
up the future of Mac hardware as we know
it is changing everything
the new MacBooks and the M1 chip that
powers it resulted in an energy
efficient chip as powerful as some
desktop CPUs
what most people are missing is that
this isn't an ordinary MacBook the M1
chip represents the culmination of a
decade of planning and a radical shift
in the consumer Computing industry on
the surface putting a mobile chip in
Apple's best-selling computer seems
really stupid but when you look deeper
it makes a whole lot of sense
as you'll see later it's actually a
classic case of disruption as defined by
Clay Christensen in 1997.
so how did Apple do this well the
Journey of how Apple got to this point
will be the subject of today's episode
you will also see how Intel CEO refused
to work on the iPhone and made one of
the biggest mistakes in Tech History
[Music]
and what Apple has done we first must go
through some quick history
central processing units or CPUs are the
brain of computers
they do all the billions of calculations
a second to make our devices run
CPUs run on water called instructions
these are the fundamental tiny bits of
data that tell our computers what to do
for example add these two numbers
together fetch this number from memory
that kind of thing when you group these
commands together they're called an
instruction set
in the emerging battle between mobile
and desktop CPUs it would be the
variations in how these instruction sets
were handled that would make all the
difference
since its founding in 1968 by Robert
Noyes and Gordon Moore Intel has been
the gatekeeper of mainstream computer
CPUs
they would gain the name x86 after a
series of popular chips in the late 70s
and early 80s that ended in the number
86.
the x86 instruction set architecture
would go on to dominate the industry
from the 1980s chip manufacturers would
begin to add more and more complicated
instructions to be perceived as better
to a non-suspecting buyer
over time these instructions made the
Chip's functionality bloated
precious and limited physical space on
the chip was being taken up by fancy
instructions that were hardly ever used
by the rest of the system
meanwhile in the UK in 1983 a company by
the name of acorn computers decided to
go down a different path instead of
making things more and more complicated
why not take a simpler approach
this mode of thinking was called risk A
reduced instruction set Computing as
opposed to the bloated Sisk from
companies like Intel
some people are saying Risk Technology
is the wave of the future other people
are saying risk is already a passe
technology what does this expert think
well Stuart the current IBM PC line that
they're based upon a processor called
the 8086. it's kind of a messy
architecture so risk is this is a new
starting point we can say okay here's a
simpler instruction set faster less code
space so if you talk about risk is that
a philosophy a way you design a machine
architecture or is it a specific set of
instructions so no it certainly is a
philosophy or a style and in fact it's a
style which differs depending on what
you're trying to do the main idea is not
to add any complexity to the machine
unless it pays for itself by how
frequently you would use it out of this
came the acorn risk machine project
otherwise known as arm this was the
birth of the type of chips that would be
used in all of our smartphones in the
coming decades
so in this episode for simplicity's sake
we'll just refer to wrist chips as
simplified CPUs and Sisk chips as
complex CPUs
while developing the first arm chip
during testing something unexpected
happened here Professor Steve Ferber
speaks about how he started the arm
project
as we set about designing the arm
we didn't really expect to pull it off
okay firstly we thought this risk idea
is so obvious that Big Industry will
pick up on it and will get trampled
underfoot we expected to go into this
project finding out why it wasn't a good
idea to do it and the and the obstacle
just never emerged from the Mist we just
kept moving forward through the fog
until eventually we had a fully working
arm chip in our hands
I don't think it was day one but a few
days later we decided we'd better
measure the power consumption so I
turned the arm chip on ran some run some
code on it looked at the ammeter and it
was reading zero
and I knew we designed a fairly low
power chip but this was a bit remarkable
and it turned out that actually had in
inserting the ammeter into the power
supply I'd failed to connect the power
supply
and so no current was flowing through
the ammeter but the chip was still
running so hang on so it wasn't just you
didn't connect diameter it was actually
that you didn't connect the chip to the
power supply yes there was no power
supply connection to the chip yet and
yet it was running
by 1985 they had their first prototype
and by 1987 the first computer based on
arm was produced the acorn Archimedes
and from here Armwood license its
designs to other manufacturers for them
to build
at first being low power was a nice side
effect but it didn't have much of an
advantage for desktop machines
but as portable Computing devices
started showing up arm became the first
choice they were used in everything from
nokius to Ericsson phones
so how were These Arm chips so efficient
[Music]
when we talk about computer CPUs we
measure them in gigahertz and that means
clock cycles per second
simplified CPUs such as arm generally
will do one simple instruction per clock
cycle while desktop chips may use many
cycles to complete one complex
instruction
this means more power consumption less
efficiency and more heat produced
multiply this by hundreds of millions of
times a second and the issue starts to
become clear
in some desktop CPUs some of the complex
instructions can take a dozen clock
Cycles or more to complete
though contrary to popular belief both
kinds of processes were flourishing
during the 1990s
in the early days simple instruction set
designs were great for engineering and
Graphics so much so that computers using
the technology helped create films such
as Jurassic Park toy story and more
simple instruction CPUs were also used
in the 3D Graphics chip of the Nintendo
64 and other early game consoles
but the desktop Market safely belonged
to Intel
this symbol outside says inside you'll
find a legacy of technological
leadership the Intel Pentium processor
for the next generation of compatible
power
Intel the computer inside
[Music]
in 1991 Apple IBM and Motorola combine
forces to create the power PC chip
interestingly powerpc was a desktop chip
but use Simple instruction set
Apple would proudly put them in their
computers during the 90s
the simple instruction arm CPU would get
a huge boost in the form of the iPod in
2001. Apple's use of the arm chip in the
iPod was a microcosm for arms popularity
and portable devices
from mobile phones to MP3 players by
2002 there were 1 billion arm chips and
devices
despite using arms simple CPUs in their
portable devices Apple's power PC
collaboration with IBM and Motorola
wasn't going so well
their simple CPUs were falling behind
Intel
it was looking like Intel and their
complex CPU way of thinking was the way
to go for the desktop market so Apple
left power PC behind
and yes it's true
we are going to begin the transition
from the power PC to Intel processors
when Intel signed the deal with Apple in
2005 Apple was already thinking of what
comes next
they went to Intel to see if they could
power the upcoming iPhone now at this
time a moment occurred that Intel would
never forget
Paul ottolini CEO of Intel at the time
didn't see such a deal working out as it
was far outside their specialty
believe that Intel could earn enough
money by building mobile chips for
Apple's new iPhone Revenue wasn't going
to cover the research costs also he
thought he couldn't imagine the iPhone
selling well this obviously proved to be
a huge missed opportunity
the iPhone launched in 2007 using a
simple instruction arm CPU if Intel's
CEO Paul ottolini had made the deal
happen they would have had a massive
stake in the iPhone business but
unfortunately for Intel Apple was moving
on without them
in 2008 Apple would sign an architecture
license with arm this was so they could
design their own chips from the ground
up they would also buy a PA semi a
company whose founder previously
specialized in high performance arm chip
development this was a key strategic
acquisition for Apple it gave them the
expertise and potential to design some
of the best arm chips and to put them on
the road to disrupt Intel and their x86
processors
in 2012 Apple releases their first fully
custom designed CPU it would be
codenamed Swift and was used in the
iPhone 5. this was in contrast to using
off-the-shelf designs from arm as it had
previously done
this new Apple built chip was two times
as fast as the previous chip
even for being a first generation chip
it had impressive performance when
compared to the mobile competition but
it wasn't head turning
the real shock to the industry came the
next year in 2013 with the Apple A7 in
the iPhone 5S
Apple's early adoption of a 64-bit
architecture stunned everybody they even
beat arm's own CPU teams by more than a
year
arms owned 64-bit design wouldn't be
seen until late 2014 in the form of the
Galaxy S4
Apple famously called their 2013 chip
design quote desktop class architecture
most people thought it was just Apple
bragging but this wording actually was a
hidden clue as to where the company was
heading as you'll soon see their latest
custom chip does actually hold up with
desktop PCS
by 2014 there were 50 billion arm chips
in the world all the while Apple kept
selling a bunch of iPhones and making a
heap of money
and do you know what all of this Revenue
can buy
a ton of r d
the chips inside of the iPhone kept
evolving and improving getting faster
while using less power
by the end of 2018 with Apple's a12 chip
it was looking like apple was catching
up to Intel
in this chart the gray dots are Apple
and the blue squares are Intel
in the past five years Intel managed to
increase their Flagship performance by
about 28 percent
in the same time Apple managed to
improve their designs by 300 and this is
where things start getting very strange
the Intel chip at the top of this chart
the core I9 10900k is a desktop chip
that uses 125 watts of power it's the
kind that you have to plug into a wall
meanwhile Apple's A14 chip in the iPhone
12 the one in the top right hand corner
that performs better than the chip I
just mentioned uses 5 watts and is
powered by a phone battery
YouTuber Jonathan Morrison does a test
of exporting a heavy duty video file on
a desktop versus an iPhone 12. check
this out this is a fairly capable
machine at 10 core it's got a beefy GPU
and what I have here uh is Sony fx9 HDR
10-bit footage we're going to start that
I'm gonna throw this open we're gonna
see a couple things right we're going to
see the CPU cores just Spike up and you
should start hearing the fans now in the
meantime while this thing is chugging
along
I have the iPhone 12 mini little guy
keep in mind this thing is still
slowly chugging along I'm gonna open up
iMovie
create a movie
the first thing you notice is just the
scrubbing in the playback right so this
is a fanless teeny tiny iPhone 12. and
just butter so what I'm going to do is
take that
export make sure we're in 4k
on 20 battery HDR
keep in mind this thing's still going
it's got a nice little head start right
[Music]
[Music]
so this is on a battery about 20 left
no fan
and this is a Decked Out iMac
the thing tonight here is that the
iPhone chip does have Hardware
acceleration but it can be argued that
this is just a smarter way of doing
things anyway the M1 chip is even faster
than this
looking at this and the speed at which
Apple's chip performance was
accelerating Apple pretty much was
forced to ditch Intel and their x86
platform intel was just too slow to
innovate they were struggling to keep up
with the manufacturing technology
whereas Apple could Outsource
manufacturing of their custom armed
designs to others like Samsung
performance lead of Intel's desktop CPUs
were being evaporated right in front of
everyone's eyes
by 2019 the iPad was more powerful than
the Intel MacBook Pro of the previous
year this is something I mentioned in a
previous episode
the speed of all of these advancements
would come back to shock people in 2020
[Music]
this episode so far you might be keen on
small Tech news and today's sponsor
morningbrew
Apple has announced that from the 1st of
January they'll be lowering their App
Store fees from 30 to 15 this is in
response to the Anti-Trust allegations
from the United States and EU Apple has
also agreed to pay 113 million dollars
for its scandal in slowing down old
iPhones to make their batteries last
longer let's chump change if you ask me
I came to know these stories through
morningbrew a great way to catch up on
news in the morning you can get up to
speed in just five minutes instead of
wasting time going to different sources
it's informative and makes news less dry
and boring it gets sent to your inbox
each weekday and Saturday and it's free
so there's no reason not to subscribe to
morningbrew if you're interested in
business finance or Tech click the link
in the description below to sign up to
morningbrew it only takes 15 seconds
all right so where were we
arm chips have been used for low power
uses like in Mobile phones Intel refused
to make chips for the iPhone and then
Apple decided to do it themselves by
acquiring a company and then with this
expertise Apple has pushed the state of
the art forward until mobile phone chips
were comparable to PCS
and now it was time for arm and apple to
take on the PC head on
in November of 2020 Apple reveals its
new processor to take on the PC it's
called the M1 the company's first custom
CPU designed with Max in mind it
features 16 billion transistors 35 more
than the A14 inside the new iPhone 12
and because it's arm-based and shares
the same DNA as the iPhone the new
Macbook can run iPad and iPhone apps all
with transistors on a five nanometer
process
early testing of the chip is blowing the
online tech reviewer Community off their
feet
proceeded to annihilate the other tests
posting 1744 on single core which is
faster than every Intel Mac ever made
now badeem really wants to jump in in
front of the camera and give his opinion
all right so I have a 2018 base 15 inch
MacBook Pro I tried playing League of
Legends it's not smooth it's glitchy you
get drop frames and I'm just blown away
that we're getting native resolution
everything maxed out getting around 60
FPS and you have a dedicated graphics
card yes it has a dedicated ship and
this is under Rosetta not even on time
it's not even optimized for Apple
silicon these are legit this is super
fast to the point where I had a friend
he actually makes an app a pretty well
known app he uses a Hackintosh 3950x 16
core really decked out system
specifically for development right this
is his build time somehow these M1
devices are keeping up one of them being
fanless
it's pretty crazy and this was the
moment like when I got the numbers back
I was like this is this is real Apple
silicon is real
if apple as a company is to continue on
their current performance trajectory
it's going to be insane to see
here's a quote from Ananda Tech quote
Apple claims the M1 to be the fastest
CPU in the world given our data on the
older A14 beating all of Intel's designs
and just falling short of amd's newest
Zen 3 chips we can certainly believe
that apple and the M1 will be able to
achieve that claim AMD has shown lots of
progress lately however it'll be
incredibly hard to catch up with Apple's
power efficiency if Apple's performance
trajectory continues at this pace the
x86 performance Crown might never be
regained end quote
when you're aware of the wider
applications of arm in the real world it
was only a matter of time
the fastest supercomputer in the world
the Japanese fugaku is three times
faster than IBM's and it uses arm
architecture
though this is the Clincher needing a
more powerful computer isn't relevant to
everyone but having more efficiency and
less power consumption is and it's
something that everyone can notice
clay Christensen who wrote the book
innovator's dilemma in 1997 states that
disruptive Innovations quote involve no
new technologies rather they consist of
components built around proven
technologies that are put together in
novel architectures offering the
consumer a set of attributes never
before available and he goes on they are
quote initially used only by the
unsophisticated consumers of the low end
markets
so arm chips have existed since the
1980s
but in the current day they've
traditionally only been used for lower
end items like smartphones for example
though putting arm chips in a laptop has
existed for a long time Windows has done
this for years but having an armchip
that is so powerful that it can reach
the top end of the consumer computer
Market is new
Christensen who wrote this quote shows a
chart of disruptive Technologies 25
years ago look carefully at this
what does it look like
Steve Jobs even had something to say
about this
speaking at the launch of his next
computer he said that all systems and
architectures have about 10 years of
life at the start you have to get people
to build applications for it and around
year 5 it reaches its architectural Peak
quote then it goes on what you might
call a Glide slope the architecture is
everything it's going to ever be at that
point
foreign
so what about program compatibility well
according to early reviews the CPU is so
powerful that it has similar or better
performance running apps that weren't
even designed for it
according to the verge it's so good that
they couldn't even tell if the apps
running were coded for arm or not
so in conclusion despite no upgradable
Ram a hefty upgrade price and no
external GPU support the big story here
is the chip architecture and nothing
else
it's proving that arm can have an
inherent advantage in the laptop and
desktop space this moment was decades in
the making I feel honored to have been
around to witness it things are going to
get super interesting from here on out
and I can only hope that competition
arises from this moment
this is so us as consumers can win
though it's strange how there are those
out there who get upset over this can't
we just enjoy the progress that's being
made instead of ridiculing each other
over our technology preferences I'm just
happy that the technology is moving and
competition may come from it
this performance increase is the biggest
Gap that we've seen in many many years
and I think it's awesome
and that's the end of the story so
thanks for watching are you guys excited
for future laptops that have extremely
long battery life and have the CPU power
of desktops these kinds of machines can
be less expensive and do wonders for
students and professionals alike
anyway that's it from me I do want to
make a quick mention that I've got some
new merch just in time for the holiday
season so if you're feeling festive you
can pick some up in the description
below anyway my name is the gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
[Music]
[Music]